foreign
people I'm still Dave Rubin this is
still the Reuben report and welcome to
another Friday Round Table Extravaganza
we're gonna dive right into it joining
me today is an author a mathematician a
guy who's recently back on the Twitter
machine and a professional Troublemaker
James Lindsay and the editor-in-chief of
the post-millennial and now I think as
of like today the new editor-in-chief of
human events as well Libby Emmons James
Libby welcome to the Reuben report
hey thank you thanks Dave before we get
to anything guys I want to make note
because I know the people on the
internet they're very critical they
stare at every little thing on the
computer screen and they may be noting
that my left eye is a little swollen
right now uh Justin my oldest he
scratched me yesterday in the eye I was
kind of rubbing it all night and it's a
little swollen don't worry I'm not being
it's not elder abuse or anything like
that but I am using a child's teething
toy to uh you know who has has a little
Comfort uh in between segments so there
you go but you people have nothing to
worry about I'm doing just fine all
right let's get right to it we're doing
like a recap of the week and some of the
some of the wacky stories that we
actually couldn't get to uh through
Monday through Thursday so here we go
first off Greta thundberg everyone loves
her the climate well I wasn't I almost
said the climate c word but no no no
she's look she's a chick she's uh no
sorry
I love it I'm going to adopt that yeah I
know that's actually like I feel like
that's like right out of Curb Your
Enthusiasm or something Greta thundberg
Mrs Green energy you know who fakes
these arrests every now and again while
she was detained once again this time in
Oslo Norway for protesting a wind farm
which I thought they were four wind
farms it's all very confusing take a
look
[Applause]
[Music]
it all feels very staged James I don't
know if you saw the one a couple weeks
ago where they full-on staged it where
she was literally taking selfies with
the police officers as they were
arresting her it's like is anything
about any of this climate stuff real or
is this just all absolute theater and
basically 90 of the world is falling for
it
I think it's probably almost all theater
uh the world is being run into the
ground by theater kids kind of all over
the place it very much feels that way uh
what people gotta have gotta understand
though is this is a tactic they
understand what they're doing there's a
book that the the left row it's an
update for Rules for Radicals which a
lot of people have heard of Saul
alinsky's famous uh handbook for
Radicals and it's called Beautiful
trouble and in beautiful trouble one of
the core principles of activism today is
uh that uh that that you are to frame
out that you're this kind of victim at
all times and so what they do is they
stage these situations maybe she really
gets arrested maybe it's fake but the
point is that the antifa does this all
the time they get it so that what's
shown on camera looks very dramatic
police carrying her out she's a she's a
slumpy sack of potatoes it's so dramatic
she's standing up for her principles so
well and what they do is they as we saw
with the previous episode they cut off
the front they cut off the back they
make it look like it's this dramatic
scene when in fact it's fake or it's
banal or how boring are these things at
this point but it's a tactic to drum up
uh the idea that there are highly
committed people rather than cynical
operators doing these kinds of things
and pushing for this agenda Libby the
performative part of this I'm really
fascinated by what James said because
yesterday we played a clip of Randy
Weingarten who's the teachers union
president and she was outside the
capitol or outside the Supreme Court
actually screaming about the potential
decision uh related to student debt
relief and and it was theater to me as
James described theater kids it was just
this emotive lunacy having nothing to do
with what the laws are or what it says
in the Constitution related to student
debt which it says nothing and that
thing but it still gets people it still
gets people right
yeah it sure does I do agree with James
about Greta thornberg she probably
should have finished her education at
some point instead of going on about all
of this nonsense and with Randy
Weingarten she just doesn't doesn't want
the educational system that she is
essentially running in so many ways to
be held accountable for a bunch of kids
who grow up and don't know anything and
then take really stupid courses of
studies at universities come out of
school can't get a job in their field
can't pay their student loans back you
know because uh they've undertaken this
garbage plan of action
um so yeah she wants to see all those
student loans forgiven so that people
don't have to turn around and be mad at
her for having provided them with not an
education at all
so with the climate thing in mind take a
look at this video from CNBC uh this is
Goldman Sachs CEO David Solomon
responding to a question related to ESG
this is vanguard's uh CEO just wrote
this recently said we cannot state that
ESG environmental social and governance
investing is better performance wise
than broad index investing our Research
indicates that ESG investing does not
have any advantage over broad-based
investing what do you think of that as
somebody who I think has advocated for
the ideas around ESG well I I'm I'm a
big advocate for climate transition but
it's just that it's a transition that's
going to go on over a long period of
time I think one of the things we do as
an asset manager is we meet the needs of
capital allocators and capital
allocators are interested in allocating
some Capital not all of the capital some
Capital towards Technologies towards
opportunities that are driving the
transition that are making the world
more sustainable you know for all of us
and so I think it's important for us as
an asset manager to participate in that
but what do you make of the political
blowback and how is that impacted your
thinking about all this I I the the
political blowback really hasn't
affected my thinking that meaningfully
I've always been of the belief that it's
important for us to try to be
constructive and allocating risk capital
and driving risk Capital toward
technologies that can accelerate the
transition but it's a transition it's
going to take decades
James I feel like you're gonna have a
field day with this one so the
questioner the interviewer is Andrew
Sorkin I actually think he did a pretty
decent job there in essence he's saying
hey these ESG funds don't really do much
of anything and immediately the Goldman
Sachs CEO starts talking about climate
transition but I don't know that the
average person who invests in a fund
that Goldman Sachs is managing is really
thinking oh what can I do for the
environment they generally want to make
a couple bucks on their investment
take it away oh my God I could talk
about this for the entire show can you
give can you give the people the
simplest I know my audience knows it but
can you give them the simplest uh
explanation of ESG first before we go
any further yeah so ESG it stands for e
is environmental s is social and G is
governance it's it's a measuring stick
that they're using to judge corporations
and institutions about how compliant
they are with whatever they whether it's
at the United Nations where ESG was
created in 2003 whether it's at Davos
whatever these you know Grand pubas and
oligarchs decide are acceptable
environmental social and governing
policies for corporations and
institutions uh that they score
institutions on how well they comply
with those particular mandates so it's a
tool of control it's actually a social
credit system for corporations in large
institutions so that's what ESG is it
hides itself under the the fake idea
that certainly good Environmental Policy
social policy and
um go it was corporate governance could
lead to better long-term investment
portfolios if they were done maybe in a
realistic way as opposed to under the
dictates of Al Gore or Cloud Schwab or
something like this but what the guy
said is is actually amazing well he said
is so shocking so we see now that ESG is
failing there's a gigantic Crusade
against esj which I'm happy to take a
fair share of the credit for starting
and and unfortunately or fortunately
whatever this fella is like I don't care
about the blowback I care about a
transition a complete transition of our
system and a climate transition he calls
it but this is a transition to climate
communism it's a transition to more
control centralized control more what
they call Global cooperation toward
their central control meaning everybody
has to do it or else there will be
sanctions there'll be fines there'll be
I don't know maybe they'll just destroy
our infrastructure or something until we
comply there'll be another pandemic who
knows there's going to be all these kind
kinds of things that we have to do to
make sure that everybody complies so
that we can transition to a new
sustainable economy as they describe it
in fact the ESG tool is used to prop up
the United Nations agenda 2030
sustainable development goals he calls
it a transition they call those 17 goals
to transform our world and that's the
same transition transform it's the same
program but the goal is to shift onto a
model they call stakeholder capitalism
what they call a circular economy where
we consume our own waste and which
sounds delicious and very much like a
snake eating its own tail but in the
grossest possible way
and this is their objective to make what
if you look back through the the Marxist
literature in the 50s and 60s and 70s
they were writing that the problem with
capitalism isn't that IT immiserates
workers like they like Marx had said
it's that it's not sustainable so we
have to make capitalism sustainable in
some way while simultaneously making
socialism productive and what we're
dealing with under ESG and the
sustainable development goals is the bid
to do this a global scale and to force
all of us into it eating bugs and living
in pods and 15-minute cities and all of
this nonsense Libby is this just one of
the things that it's like sort of not
sexy enough for the average person to
understand so they might have some money
in a Goldman Sachs fund or in something
that's ancillary related and they may
not even realize that actually the
companies are not going to do the best
thing to say get a return on your
investment but rather climate transition
and everything else that James just
described
yeah I do think that is an issue and I
think that your average consumer of
financial products is not looking to
save the world by investing they're just
looking to have something in their
retirement so that perhaps they don't
have to lean on their kids or the
government as they age and the other
thing too about this
um and consumers are not I think at
their base looking for all of this
nonsense but um the other piece of it is
that all of these Dei initiatives and
climate initiatives that are being
pushed through with ESG don't actually
do what they purport to do right so when
you say like we're investing in Wind
we're investing in solar we're investing
in all of these things they're only
looking at the final product and what
that means for the consumption of fossil
fuels at like the consumer level they're
not looking at the manufacturing
processes of solar panels for example or
lithium batteries or superconductors or
the kind of cells that are needed to
store this kind of energy and what that
takes so they're only looking at these
very limited areas and it's the limited
areas that can make these people feel
good about themselves because they're
not seeing the detrimental impacts but
at the same time the rest of the world
is seeing these detrimental impacts
we're seeing issues environmental issues
created with wind farms off the coasts
um you know the whales dying all of this
kind of stuff so the
um the goals are not even being the
stated goals are not even being met by
this nonsense and it is going to damage
people's Investments if you're a
consumer of financial product and you're
looking to do something activist in the
world don't do it with your money do it
with your own self go out there and you
know pick up some trash by the Riverbend
what have you whoa whoa whoa you're
asking young people to actually do
something not just say they're doing
something yes yes radical it's my take
yeah true radical uh but speaking of
stated goals that are not really doing
what they're supposed to be doing I
remember a feminist movement a long time
ago that was about equality women wanted
equality in the workplace and everywhere
else but unfortunately that is very
little to do with the the modern
feminist movement and as you guys know
it's very important March we just got
out of Black History Month was February
and I celebrated every day this is
women's what is it women's history month
are we calling it are we calling it
International women's month and Hershey
which I thought their whole thing was
about making good chocolate they put out
this incredible ad to celebrate the
moment my name is Faye Johnstone I'm the
executive director of wisdom to action
we can create a world where everyone is
able to live in public space as their
honest and authentic selves see the
women changing how we see the future at
Hershey's Canada
Libby will do women first
um she's a dude man Chick yeah I mean
what
She's a Man baby for real yeah so Canada
is totally off the rails it's not even a
real country it's totally fake place at
this point you know right oh wait just
to be clear this came from Canada's
Hershey subsidiary or whatever yeah
because it has that two at the beginning
of the LGBT alphabet soup and the two is
for two spirit
um which I don't know how it's not
cultural appropriation to put that in
your very Western weird thing but what
have you Justin Trudeau knows and we all
just have to count on that yeah I'm
personally very sick and tired of men
standing up there with long hair and
makeup on and telling me they know
better than anyone else than any woman
what it is to be a woman I'm sick of
empowering a whole bunch of essentially
straight white men to uh get up there
and tell us that they're women uh while
they claim to be lesbians and demand
access to all sorts of women's spaces
the whole thing is so marvelously insane
that I think a lot of people when they
first started seeing this coming around
the bend just thought that's so
obviously stupid that can't be the way
that we're going with these kinds of
things and now it is now here it is oh
but we can James can you please put this
chick in her place as a woman yourself
yeah you gotta like settle down here for
this month Libby
um like just yeah just hold up uh well
what I see is a chocolate bar that's got
nuts in it that's not being advertised
as having nuts in it but maybe people
have peanut allergies you never know I
got it I got it yeah right
um so I mean that dude has a vocal fry
down I wish I could do that uh that's a
woman thing if we can celebrate in woman
month is vocal fry septum piercing no
but what we see is the complete
inversion of reality what we see is
another opportunity as as you saw to
talk about
reality in upside down world this is
your authentic self she called or he
called it called itself authentic self
literally pretending to be what you're
not literally demanding people celebrate
and affirm you for what you're not and
that's actually the magic formula it
starts off with we should tolerate this
it progresses to we have to accept this
it goes beyond that and we have to now
celebrate it and then at some point we
have to participate in it to some degree
we have to participate in the LIE we
have to participate in the delusion if
you don't want to eat the the nuts no
nuts chocolate bar you're probably a
bigot if you don't want this man in a
woman's space you're definitely a bigot
if you aren't interested in his uh lady
thing you are as a woman you are
definitely transphobic and you make all
of your sexual decisions and personal
decisions in your life based on genitals
and how disgusting in crass you are
of course what we see throughout is just
projection total projection uh of severe
pathology that is being encouraged and
affirmed especially in children
um rather than
dealt with treated tamped down the the
rollover institutions especially our
schools for example children will see
commercials like this they may have
questions they should go to the school
the officials in the school should be
bringing them back to reality not
encouraging them into the delusion there
is no other dysphoric if we want to use
that word condition that we encourage
that we we push people kids further into
we don't say oh my gosh you're so
anorexic let's uh get you liposuction
and do a gastric bypass on you to help
you out we don't do that anywhere else
we say we have to bring you back to
reality we have to help you in other
ways it's a catastrophe and and what's
interesting also is that to link it to
the ESG part of this it's like Hershey
could have done an ad for international
women's month and just shown women
eating chocolate and no one would have
cared or maybe people would have watched
it or not watch it so it's almost like
this clearly is by Design either because
of the ideology that you're describing
or just because they want to get the
clicks and Views and in this case
they're doing it I don't know if you
guys know I live in the Free State of
Florida I've mentioned it once or twice
on the show and we're doing something
about this nonsense when it comes to our
schools and our corporations here's
Governor Ron DeSantis and you got a lot
of Corporations too they're getting
involved in the race game we know
they're already getting involved in the
transgender game you had a little tussle
with Disney is Corporate America on
notice with Ron DeSantis as you get a
little bit of a bigger profile
so my view is is I got to protect the
people of Florida their freedoms and if
woke corporations are threatening their
freedoms then I have to contend with
that and I have to stand up for them so
for example we passed the stop woke act
in Florida that yes ban CRT in the K-12
schools but it also gave employees of
private corporations the ability to opt
out of this CRT training where they're
basically made to self-flagellate based
on their race we don't think that that's
appropriate so yes we're willing to step
up and support people's freedoms at the
end of the day you have a right to make
your own decisions live freely without
having the left's agenda crammed down
your throat and whether that's in a
school or whether that's be at the hands
of a multinational corporation we're on
your side not on theirs
Libby isn't this just what we've all
been waiting for for a long time like a
politician to just calmly cleanly say
the truth and help us get out of this
endless bottomless pit that they've
thrown us into
yeah I do think that that's right and
it's interesting that DeSantis takes
this perspective and then from the
federal government you have these
endless pushes of diversity equity and
inclusion executive orders uh the
president just wants to rule by Fiat
from the Oval Office and he's
instructing every single federal agency
to enact additional staff and bring in
all of these extra people to make sure
that the agencies are being compliant
with all of these uh advancing Equity
goals no one really knows what advancing
Equity means except for destroying a
meritocracy and reducing all of our
government agencies and programs to
race-based initiatives that are not fair
that are not um at all egalitarian and
yeah I think that across the country
people appreciate what DeSantis is doing
we saw that with the um parental rights
and education bill which was marvelously
popular across the country no matter how
much the progressive left tried to slam
it as don't say gay which a simple read
of I think was a three-page bill will
show you that it has nothing to do with
that at all the word gay is not in the
bill I was with the governor in the
first lady three days ago showing them
pictures of my kids this thing is so
stupid uh James did you see I feel like
you must have tweeted about this and
maybe I missed it because Twitter's
still so screwy this guy Sam I think
it's Sam Brighton who was the like
assistant secretary to nuclear waste
something or other I don't think he I
don't think he considers himself trans
but I guess he dresses off in like a
woman it's non-binary oh he's okay so
he's non-binary but it turns out that
this guy has been stealing luggage for
years from airports you know when you go
downstairs to get your luggage after the
flight and it now has turned out that in
2018 he stole a bag of luggage from a
black woman and has been wearing her
dresses and posting pictures yeah a
fashion designer nobody so you have a
man and dressing like a woman stealing a
and he's white stealing a black woman's
dresses wearing them and of course he's
Progressive I mean it's like what
I don't even have a question on that you
want to just do something over there
I'll just riff a little I'm glad you
brought that up because it actually ties
back to the previous segment it ties
back to this ESG issue ties back to even
what DeSantis said because DeSantis is
trying to protect people from workplace
he said self-flagellations these are
actually brainwashing sessions these are
maoist brainwashing sessions that's easy
to prove once you study Mao which they
don't let us do in our Red washed
education uh we have they say
whitewashed it's actually Red washed
it's completely communist uh
sympathizing but what you have in
international women's month or whatever
whatever women's History Month whatever
March now is for the first time in
history is and I saw that I saw this
coming about a month or two ago and and
this this character is a perfect example
of it so is the Hershey person what we
have is this push towards something
they're calling women plus which I think
is women plus a hot dog but I'm not
quite positive what the plus is
um it's women plus Girls plus and in
fact what they're saying is that this
new feminist push that they're bringing
out to revitalize another turn of the
the identity politics screw on America
is going to be lgbtq plus inclusive so
it's not even women's month anymore it's
this deliberate push into this so we
have to celebrate this guy who's
stealing an immigrant black woman's high
fashion design dresses we have to
celebrate that because even though it's
non-binary or whatever whatever the same
character wants to be this is women plus
and what people have to understand is
they're going to try to suck you in by
saying no if you if you don't support
women in international women's month
you're some kind of a terrible person
but by the way what is a woman well we
know what a woman is and it's women plus
and we're going to show you women plus
uh and we're just going to keep doing
this women plus and so what you're
getting is a bunch of frankly what it's
going to be is a big leverage campaign
primarily on corporations which will
fall for it because they're completely
lost in ESG and in in white Suburban
liberal wine moms to accept that the
definition of woman has expanded to
woman plus and trans women are women
plus is going to be a completely true
statement because women plus will be
defined to accept them and the the goal
will be to get people in institutional
positions to accept women Plus in these
trainings at work will be geared toward
getting women to accept and men to
accept that women plus is the correct
way to understand women under this new
push under this new fake month that
they've created out of thin air and
decided we all have to participate in
James as well said as that was you could
have just said she doesn't look great in
an off-the-shoulder number or he or
whatever it is but but to prove houses
it's true I think that's what it was
really all boiling down to but to show
you how stupid this whole thing is we
played it a couple of times during the
campaign when Joe Biden repeatedly said
but there's one moment where he really
drove it home repeatedly said that it
should not be the sex on your birth
certificate that sends you to a male or
female prison it should be what sex you
identify as now we know that biological
men are going to women's prisons and
raping and beating women apparently this
is the feminist position now Merrick
Garland was asked about just that
when it comes to federal prisons are you
aware that 1200 prisoners are requesting
to be sent from a male prison to a
female prison
I'm not no okay
uh what is our policy when it comes to
allowing a male prisoner to
be transitioned into a female prison
I I think if you're generally asking the
question of how um
uh trans people are dealt with in a
Bureau of Prisons my understanding is
that these are determinations about
where they're placed or where people are
placed in general have to do with
individualized determinations regarding
the security of that individual and the
management of the prison these are done
on a case-by-case basis that's my
understanding are you aware of any
policy guidelines that they use to make
that determination I think there is a
policy guideline along the lines that I
just said that that day I would I would
like for the Bureau of Prisons to send
it to us are you concerned that if a
biological male is sent to a female
prison that could be a risk to female
prisoners I think every uh person in
prison has to be dealt with with dignity
and respect
well every person except the chicks in
the women's prison apparently uh for the
record I watched every episode of Orange
Is the New Black and frankly a woman's
prison seems far scarier to me than a
Men's prison Libby
surprise I guess not surprised like what
I've talked to I've talked to women who
um are out of prison but who were in
prison with men I've talked to women who
are currently serving time alongside men
in the women's prisons and these are
real problems um unfortunately when you
bring up something like this why are
there men in women's prisons no one
really cares because these women are
already at the bottom of society they're
women they are criminals they in many
cases are poor they were already in many
cases subject to domestic abuse and
violence
um which led in a lot of cases to their
arriving in prison in the first place so
one woman that I talked to who is
currently serving time in the central
California Women's Correctional Facility
has told me about when men come into the
prisons there they self-id in they are
fully intact uh they have not cut off
their hot dogs everything's still
perfectly functioning and the the
prisons will
they will vacate an eight woman cell in
order to accommodate one man who will
then be housed in that cell they are
given roommates
um who are women and they end up in many
cases in sexual relationships with these
women it's not just abuse and rape but
it's also the entirely changing Dynamic
that happens when a man a man enters a
woman's face and there's rivalries and
things like this
um this woman was also telling me about
how a trans inmate
impregnated a woman at the prison and
then beat her to the point where she
miscarried because uh this was not
something that they wanted to have
exposed and the fetus was uh the
miscarried fetus was buried in the
prison yard she's told me that guards
are aware of this people are aware of
this but no one really wants to talk
about it there are women who are
advocating for these women who are in
prison who are being doubly subjected
there this is a cruel and unusual
punishment in a lot of cases there's a
man in a California women's prison who
is currently housed with the mother of
the children that he um murdered so
that's interesting as well that happens
in many cases there's cases in the UK
where women who were raped are forced by
judges to refer to their rapists as she
because that rape is determined after
the rape and while involved in the
criminal justice system that actually he
is female and this is inflicted upon
women and I would like to say we have
seen historically and that's how we
ended up with a women's History Month in
the first place women are substantially
more compliant than men women are raised
to be uh you know a little Kinder and
more compassionate it is easy to push
women around we all know we all know
this this is not a new phenomenon and so
when you have these feminist women who
came up up saying like Yay women's power
and now the men are all like hey lady
like we're actually female oh okay okay
sure we we just want to be accepted and
loved and cherished and cared for and
now you're telling us that you're
actually female we will just believe you
because you say it and you're actually
the big strong man so I yeah I think
that there's a lot of weirdness going on
here there's a lot of cognitive
dissonance among women who scream
empowerment for women and are actually
perfectly willing to subject themselves
to you know the whims of these in many
cases bigger men bigger stronger men
seems to to the point of the of the
stories that that Libby just laid out I
mean isn't Garland's response just
exactly what we get out of this
Administration related to anything
Lindsey Graham's question was pretty
good he said what is the policy and
Garland twice basically said well I I
kind of don't know the policy but the
policy is just Case by case in which
case ID right so in which case you're
just gonna let through probably I don't
know the number off the top of my head
but I'm gonna guess something like 90 of
these people who have a series of
psychological problems on top of the
physical differences and everything else
and they most likely committed a pretty
heinous act in the first place to get
them there they're going to go right
through but this is exactly what this
government has done with almost
everything right
yeah so let me give some historical
color to that because this government
has been tried before it didn't work
before it won't work this time uh
there's a character in history because
we have this Red washed education that I
mentioned before that I go all over the
country as you know I speak all over the
country I speak to audiences of hundreds
of people at a time and I ask them a
question very frequently from the stage
raise your hand if you've ever heard of
trophium lysenko that's a very famous
name in history and if you haven't heard
of it it's a bit of a problem and
virtually nobody raises their hand at a
300 people three or four or five will
raise their hand in a typical audience
even though I do this all over the place
and people follow me and I talk about
him a lot what we're looking at is a
phenomenon that was what is called
lysenchoism lysenchoism is when you have
L I think it was I should say a
biologist and an agriculturalist under
Stalin he put out Soviet biology Soviet
Agriculture and he believed all kinds of
crazy things about plants and genetics
that are not true and millions of people
starved in Ukraine millions of people
starved in Russia millionaire Soviet
Union more broadly millions of people
starved again in China when Mao Zedong
picked this up and decided to use the
lysenkoist biology even though it had
killed somebody in the Soviet Union when
you have an overriding of reality that's
coming down unquestionably from a
corrupt government and here we're
looking at the Attorney General of the
United States
literally overriding basics of biology
like male and female are fundamentally
different they are not the same thing
they are not transmutable they are not
fungible when you have
these the Communist based or whatever
based ideology overriding reality as a
matter of policy what you're dealing
with is lysenchoism lysenchoism killed
millions and millions of people in the
Soviet Union and in China it will kill
millions of people in the United States
this is just one Dynamic within that
it's it's leading to the the rapes the
murders the Myriad problems in women's
prisons it's dealing with the same thing
in women's sports in girls locker rooms
then we can of course connect that back
to what it's doing to young girls I just
heard the other day that the primary
demographic of course that's getting
into the trans movement to gain social
status and character or whatever they
they're after is girls aged 10 to 14
which simultaneously through some weird
mystery I am thinking must be a mystery
there's also the demographic that is
increasing in suicide at the fastest
rate at the same time
um what a what a crazy coincidence that
is but what we have is a rejection of
reality for an ideological Drive which
is called lysenchoism and until
Americans understand that we're going
through the same motions in different
packaging that places like the Soviet
Union and places like the CCP China
under Mao Zedong already went and that
the consequences will be the same until
we understand that that ties back to
Greta Thunder also with environmental
farming or whatever where we're all
going to eat lentils nobody can have any
meat we can't have any energy whatever
this is all the same thing this is
lysenkoism brought back and millions if
not tens or hundreds of millions of
people will suffer will be castrated
will be sterilized will die will be
immiserated by these programs and to see
this from what this government is just
an echo of History it's just history
rhyming again and people I think are too
asleep at the wheel and too
underinformed because of our Red washed
education system to realize what we're
doing you had a great line in their
rejection of reality for ideological
Drive I mean that that seems to capture
it more than anything else let's just do
one more story here which is actually
connected to that very notion uh the
January 6th tapes Kevin McCarthy is
going to release them or in essence he's
given about 40 000 hours of the tapes
the security footage Etc to Tucker
Carlson and I assume at the moment
Tucker Carlson's team is going through
them and uh as I keep saying on this
show the truth is a Time release pill
and I suspect we are going to find out
some more Truth uh over the next coming
weeks as Tucker releases some of this
stuff but there was a really just
telling moment on the tell televised
mental institution known as MSNBC
journalist Dana Milbank talking about
how scary it is that we might actually
get transparency from this government
they love trans just not transparency
speaker Kevin McCarthy is under Fire for
sharing about 44
000 hours of surveillance camera footage
from January 6 with Fox News host Tucker
Carlson other media organizations
including NBC News have demanded access
to the tapes as well the speaker is more
than just the political leader they also
oversee the day-to-day administration of
the capital including security is there
something unprecedented about what
McCarthy has done here Dana
yeah I mean day after day it seems that
he breaks uh president after precedence
look I understand why the other media
are asking for the same thing the truth
is this doesn't belong in the public
domain for anybody
that's the line This doesn't belong in
the public domain we are told that there
was an Insurrection that the United
States almost fell on that day despite
these people having no plans Apparently
one guy had a Lego set he didn't even
bring it of the capital AOC was freaking
out but we should not know about this
stuff
I take it you're not surprised Libby
they're better than us and they know
right
yeah these are our superiors and we must
bow down before their Superior judgment
um I for one I'm glad that there's going
to be some transparency I think that the
people who went into the capital and the
people who were around the Capitol and
the journalists who were not
credentialed but were documenting what
was going on that day have been
substantially ill-treated and ignored
and I think that that's really a shame
especially when you compare it to the
sweetheart deals and uh you know
compassionate treatment that was given
to the rioters in the summer of 2020 I'm
thinking specifically of the ones in
Portland uh against whom I I believe so
many charges were dropped even though
they were trying to set the federal
buildings on fire repeatedly like like
night after night for more than a
hundred nights I believe it was I think
it ended up being something like 120
nights yeah this went on yeah and I'd
like to see what was really going on
there's been a lot of talk about perhaps
there were federal agents involved if
the government can disprove that then
maybe they ought to that has been talk
about and this is something that you've
seen on Tucker Carlson as well uh
Capitol police officers opening doors
and all of this kind of stuff what was
really going on what was the
relationship there what kind of
encouragement were these people getting
from law enforcement if that was
happening and uh yeah the way that they
have used January 6 as a cudgel to beat
anyone who disagrees with the leftist
progressive narrative means that we get
to see literally every second of footage
because they're going to continue to use
this against all of us who don't agree
with the Biden Administration for years
we're just seeing that you know they
keep coming out with stuff about that as
they're starting to quiet down and their
little commission had to get disbanded
at the end of the last Congress we
haven't heard as much about it but I do
respect and appreciate McCarthy for
giving over this these yeah and you know
I I will give the devil his due here I
mean McCarthy if he wanted to do this
I suppose in the most clean way maybe he
could have just released it all together
whatever that means you know just put it
out there on the internet and let people
go through it or he could have said hey
I'm giving it to Tucker but I'm also
giving it to Anderson Cooper or
something so I think there's a little
degree of by going to someone who
obviously is partisan I like Tucker but
like he is what he is obviously I'll
give them a little nudge on that but
that's not really what this is about
right James because clearly they're
going to find some stuff in there
perhaps more videos of officers
literally removing barriers and
welcoming people in and things like that
and that's the last thing that the
mainstream media wants to get out there
right
well I mean before we can give more
commentary I think we all need to have a
moment of silence for AOC
nobody has died this many times over
this this terrible event and she keeps
coming back like Freddy Krueger yeah
it's amazing but we've got to hold out
for that we've got to have a vigil I
think we should go to the border and cry
by a fence um there are a lot of things
we should be doing but the fact of the
matter is the way that they're framing
this is actually to me hilarious because
it's proof that much like January 6th
itself they don't have anything
um they're framing it that it threatens
Capital Security they this is this is
the angle that they're going after there
might be another disaster there might be
a stochastic terrorist might show up
there might be some lone wolf there
might be another coordination for a real
Insurrection since the last one was
obviously so fake
um that the friendly police officers
asking people to stay between the ropes
were able to contain it uh entirely or
whatever but they don't have anything
here this thing is a fraud and they know
it's a fraud and they they know that if
people are able to see this whether and
I do agree with you that it going to
Tucker
specifically does leave a gap in the
story that is a partisan you know uh
kind of ad hominem but at any rate it is
what it is
they realize that when this goes to the
public people are going to see through
the fraud and this I think is one of the
paralyzing fears of this regime or
Administration in general is that the
fraud is a time bomb for them it's only
a matter of time until things start to
come out the truth has a way of warming
its way out and in this case they are
desperate to try to get a clamp back on
this story because they know that it was
never what they said it was and that
they've used it as such a damaging
political political cudgel they've used
it as an excuse to jail political
opponents they've used it as an excuse
to try to rewrite our laws around uh to
try to disenfranchise president Trump
from being able to run again they've
used it in a wide variety of completely
communist ways frankly and the fraud is
going to get exposed as the truth comes
out so what they have to do is try to
put a lid on it and what is their
favorite last ditch effort when they
have to try it's usually their first
line of attack and their last line of
attack when they have to try to get on
something well of course it's that it
threatens safety in some way this is
going to threaten our safety the capital
somehow there's footage like we haven't
already seen lots of it is some are
going to compromise secret entrances to
the capital or whatever by the way did
anybody figure out who planted that bomb
has that been done yet no no we're not
allowed to ask about that one I wonder
if that's in the footage
um
so I mean
we're this is just proof that they don't
have anything and they know that they're
likely to get exposed I think it's
extremely transparent they're acting in
a paranoid and anxious way they're
bringing up completely ridiculous things
we have Dana saying that it shouldn't be
in the hands of anybody so again we go
back to the point like you said these
are our betters these are our our
Gnostic overlords who know how to
interpret everything like that footage
to come out to Insurrection which
everybody understands is fake and we're
all supposed to just accept their expert
opinion uh not promulgate you know
misinformation or disinformation like
the tapes themselves uh and that's
that's the that's the the the warp and
the weft of this entire Administration
for all this and to that point yeah to
that point so we've got one more clip
for you this is Eric swalwell now Eric
swalwell we know had a relationship with
the Chinese spy McCarthy has said this
multiple times and you know it's true
because if it wasn't true the mainstream
media would be going after McCarthy but
they're not so it is true he has talked
to people at the FBI he said it on my
show a year and a half ago but he's
repeatedly said it since he's been house
leader but anyway Eric swallow well
Democrat congressman from California
here he is freaking out over the release
of the tapes and it's fairly obvious
because it's just what you just said
James he knows there's something there
well we're seeing uh week by week that
now Kevin McCarthy has to pay a new
installment on that corrupt bargain
right so last week the installment was
to give Tucker Carlson uh unfettered
access to police footage sensitive
police footage of the Capitol on January
6. you know there's no good ending to
that uh it's it's either going to be
used to distort what happened on January
6th uh by Tucker Carlson or you just
gave the proudest boy of all a blueprint
for the capital uh that you know perhaps
who knows where that will land you know
for the next Insurrection that could be
planned
all right I really despise this guy I
mean I I at this point hate a lot of
people in government but this guy I mean
the implication he calls him the
proudest boy of all somehow that Tucker
Carlson is either a white supremacist or
something like that you know the other
piece on the Tucker part of this is that
I I feel like I can say this fairly
honestly I know Tucker well enough that
if they go through all 40 000 hours and
there's nothing there that's exactly
what he would say I don't think he's
sitting there to to edit this in a weird
way I really really do not uh but Libby
that's what this is all about right like
swalwell knows this is just going to be
another one of those things where we're
allowed to tell you the truth basically
a year or two later right
yeah and I think it's so interesting
that that keeps happening we saw that I
think we're gonna see that with the
January 6 footage we saw that with the
lab leak how many people lost their jobs
and their Twitter accounts and all of
their friends and everything for
declaring that covid came out of a lab
in Wuhan and now the FBI and the energy
Department I think maybe perhaps it came
out of a lab perhaps it was leak from a
lab uh we've seen that so many times the
thing about masks whether or not masks
work you know the two weeks to stop the
spread lockdowns all of these things the
conspiracy theorists keep being right
you know conspiracy theorist is actually
another word for way ahead of the curve
um and it's a shame what's been done to
our mainstream media I lament the loss
of you know the New York Times And The
Washington Post and all of these Outlets
that have these big departments full of
resources to go do the digging and
because of their ideological perspective
they're just not willing to do it it's a
it's a shame I think that it makes sense
that Tucker was the one to get the
footage because I think that his team is
probably pretty honest and
straightforward and like you said
they're gonna dig into it if they find
something they'll say if they don't find
something they'll say that as well and
by the way NBC would be even remotely as
um you know considerate in that regard
right and and the bigger problem would
be even if he gave one to you know one
set of it to Tucker and one set to
someone at MSNBC we're all so divided at
this point that they'll show you the
exact same thing and analyze it in a
completely different way so maybe it's a
moot point James I know you like phrases
you're a man of History you like phrases
that succinctly say things so you know
my line on this has been that truth As A
Time release pill but I for now on I
think I'm going to call this time truth
disorder what do you think about that
time truth disorder I like that actually
that's what it is it really is I mean a
friend of mine
um Wade Miller calls calls conspiracy
theories future facts and I kind of like
that as well
um but speaking of you know conspiracy
theories and uh being unable to look at
Eric swalwell's face I happen to notice
the CIA emblem over his shoulder and
kind of fixated on that while he's
sitting there talking but the the point
I really want to draw out from that clip
was that comment you regarded either
that you brought up where he he regarded
Tucker Carlson as the proudest boy of
them all and so this is that appeal to
the proud boy so I'm gonna gonna do a
call back to something I mentioned
earlier which is that book beautiful
trouble which is available online for
free I think anybody wants to understand
leftist activism needs to go read it
you're not a serious player in what's
happening if you haven't looked at
beautiful trouble another one of their
core principles is your Target's
reaction is your real action so by
provoking Society through the things
that happened in 2020 through the things
that have happened since through the
drag queens they get this organization
to come into formation called The Proud
boys the proud boys show up to things
they act in a you know
quietly or modestly or sometimes not
intimidating manner they're an
anti-antifa if you will an opposite of a
dialectical opposite of antifa and they
have become that is a reaction to the
provocations of BLM antify et cetera
that have been happening drag queen
Story Hour that have been happening
throughout the country those are
provocations they're strategic
provocations this is unconventional
warfare and they have generated that
reaction and listened to what they do
with it it comes up every single time so
when you react badly when you react the
way that they want you to react they are
weaponizing you for their narratives for
the different tools that they're going
to use for the justification to you know
have to shut things down or control
speech or control thought or control
whatever so proud boys became an emblem
in that it's the reaction and you can
actually say if you understand the
principle in beautiful trouble that that
reaction was exactly the thing that they
needed just like the event in j6 was
exactly the thing that they needed even
though it wasn't because it didn't pan
out the way that they could have really
used it to drive a narrative that
something's happening in this country
that's the opposite of what's really
happening there was an Insurrection on
January 6th to know there was an
Insurrection on November 3rd or whatever
it was previously you know so they cover
up their own Insurrection with the fake
Insurrection they cover up the fact of
antifa violence with and drag queen
Story Hour provocations drag queen
performances for children and now babies
apparently everywhere with well the
proud boys are violent and we have to
resist this anti-lgbtq hate blah blah
blah blah and so that understanding that
they are provoking reactions and using
rear actions that's what Greta does she
provokes a reaction she fake gets
arrested puts it on a camera
understanding that this is a fundamental
objective a fundamental tool of their
activism that keeps moving the ball for
them allows us to figure out ways to
short-circuit that and sidestep it so I
really just want to draw your attention
to the fact that he said proudest boy of
them all to Loop Tucker Carlson into
that narrative Arc that they're using
with so much productivity on your kind
of average not paying attention scared
Suburban wine mom or whatever that's
paying attention to these these mental
asylums called CNN and MSNBC and so on
James I don't think I can top that as a
closing to the show so I want to thank
you James you Libby you guys are awesome
as always I am going to re-ice this
thing and put a teething toy on my eye
and hopefully make it through the
weekend I thank you guys I thank
everybody for watching and actually
there's no post game show today because
I'm actually in New York right now
because I did Gutfeld last night but I
will be on Dan bongino's unfiltered
Saturday night on Fox and hopefully I
survived New York City and make it back
thanks everybody and see you on Monday